vor gut 15 Jahren am 8 august 2008
wurden in Peking die Olympischen
Sommerspiele eröffnet doch genau am
gleichen Tag jenem 08.08 gab es noch ein
anderes historisches Ereignis der Kreml
startete eine militärinvasion in
Georgien
zwar war dieser sogenannte Kaukasuskrieg
eher von Georgiens Präsident sarkash
Willi vom Zaun gebrochen worden also vom
Kreml und er war auch nach 5 Tagen schon
wieder vorbei aber in Peking blieb
trotzdem ein bitterer Nachgeschmack
diese Olympischen Spiele waren für China
das wichtigste Ereignis des Jahrzehnts
sie sollten den Prozess der
vollständigen Eingliederung des
kommunistischen Landes in die
internationale Gemeinschaft krönen doch
dieses Fest von friede freude und Völker
Verständigung und der Tag an dem das
olympische Feuer zum ersten Mal in China
auflampen wurde von Russlands
kriegerischen Bestrebungen überschattet
damals dann shisha-ping noch nicht an
der Spitze Chinas es war noch seit
Vorgänger hushin Tao der seinerzeit ist
kriegt blieb aber wegen des Datums ist
Einmarsches zutiefst verärgert über
Moskau war tja meine Lieben Zuschauer es
scheint dass ich manche Gewohnheiten nie
ändern selbst wenn in der Zwischenzeit
viel anderes passiert ist wie in einer
Art Deja Vu traf Putin seine
Entscheidung in die Ukraine
einzumarschieren wohl auch wieder just
dann als China eine weitere Olympiade
ausrichtete diesmal die Winterspiele
2022 in Peking es wird sogar vermute
dass ich in den russischen Staatsschiff
gebeten hat seine Invasion bis nach Ende
der Spiele zu verschieben ob das nun
stimmt oder nicht tatsache ist das
putinshagen nur vier Tage nach dem Ende
des Spieler in die Ukraine eingefallen
sind und seitdem ist die Haltung der
Volksrepublik China in Sachen Ukraine
Krieg äußerst ambivalent und defuss
während des ersten Jahres in dem in der
Ukraine der kriegt tobte und die
russische Armee schreckliche Verbrechen
dagegen hatte ich chinesische Diktator
geschrieben und sich nicht zu Wort
gemeldet eines ist allerdings deutlich
geworden distanziert sich immer weiter
von seinen dezenten Vorgängern denn
bilder wie diese hier werden wohl für
lange Zeit nicht vergessen werden
ja im März ein Jahr nach Beginn des
Krieges ist es dann doch passiert was
die einen bezweifelten und andere als
unvermeidlich und logisch betrachteten
die Diktatoren Chinas und
Russian feierten sich gemeinsam auf
einen bilateralen Gipfel in Moskau
[Musik]
es war zwar nicht das erste Mal dass sie
sich seit dem Beginn der Invasion
getroffen haben aber es war das erste
Mal dass dies auf höchster Ebene und im
Rahmen eines bilateralen Gipfels geschah
vielleicht haben deshalb viele
schießbesuch in Moskau als offene
Unterstützung für Putin interpretiert
als eine Möglichkeit in russischen
Staatschef auf internationale Bühne zu
legitimieren und vielleicht auch um
seine Machenschaften zu beschuldigen
umso mehr als der Besuch nur ein paar
Tage nach der Veröffentlichung von
Nachrichten wie dieser Stadt waren
Richter des Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof erlassen hauptbefehl
gegen Wladimir Putin wegen angeblicher
Kriegsverbrechen doch das war für die
beiden nicht mehr als eine Fußnote in
Wahrheit ging es bei Shisha banks Besuch
in Russland um mehr als nur ein Hände
schütteln oder eingezwungenes Lächeln
von Seiten Moskau aus war dieser Gipfel
der Versuch von Peking Zusagen für
Waffenlieferungen zu bekommen in einer
Front in der Ukraine fehlt ist
putinstruppen inzwischen bitter sowohl
an tauglichen Kriegsgerät als auch an
Munition für Peking war schieße
selbstsichere Auftritt in mos ohnehin
gegen der jüngste versuch einfach alle
mal die Hauptstadt zu werden die den
stärksten Antagonisten Washingtons
darstellt die klare Alternative zur
westlichen Führung und dafür braucht Ski
einen starken Wasser mit deutlicher
Betonung auf Wasser und eher weniger auf
stark bedeutet das nun dass sich China
letztendlich auf die Seite Russland
schlagen wird oder ist Peking wirklich
so neutral wie es mitunter zu sein
vorgibt was sind die warenabsichtlich
Chinas in diesem ungleichen
Freundschaftsspiel mit Putin und wer ist
bei dieser ganzen Geschichte eigentlich
am längeren Hebel heute werden wir all
diese spannenden Fragen natürlich
beantworten und zwar gleich nach der
knackigen Werbebotschaft unsere Sponsors
blinkist denn die Berliner Firma
blinkist hat mit ihrem Beitrag nicht nur
das heutige Video wirklich gemacht nein
wir selbst nutzen Ihre App auch um
täglich unseren eigenen wissens-horizont
zu erweitern vielleicht fragt ihr euch
ja manchmal wie wir es schaffen so viel
Wissen aus verschiedenen Bereichen
miteinander in unseren Videos zu
verknüpfen und der Schlüssel dazu ist
vor allem lesen lesen und manchmal auch
stören artikelanalysen Videos Podcasts
und vor allem Bücher mit
Grundlagenwissen das notwendig ist um
diese Information zu einem Gesamtbild
verknüpfen zu können aber was wenn man
gar nicht die Zeit dazu hat so viele
verschiedene Bücher auf einmal zu lesen
nun genau dann ist man bei blinkist
richtig denn es verschafft einem nicht
nur mehr Zeit sondern motiviert auch
noch durch die unterhaltsame Aufmachung
blinkist bringt das Wichtigste aus mehr
als 5000 Sachbüchern und Podcast auf
dein Handy und dann erlebst du einen
ungeahnten wissensbuchst anstatt Stunden
in die Lektüre eines Buches zu stecken
und es dann vielleicht gar nicht zu Ende
zu lesen siehst du dir in null Komma
nichts die immer sehr angenehm und
locker geschriebene blinkist Version
rein man merkt sofort dass da echte
Profis unter Talente am Werk sind stell
dir vor wir würden ein wertvolles aber
langes Buch in eine knackiges und leicht
verdauliches visual Politik Video Gießen
nun genau das macht blinkist ein
praktisches Beispiel dass ich immer
wieder nutze sind Bücher von Autoren mit
denen man vielleicht nicht immer einer
Meinung ist womit aber kann man seine
Horizont besser arbeiten als mit
Informationen die eben nicht aus eigenen
Bubble stammen neulich ist mir zum
Beispiel das Buch kein Kapitalismus ist
auch keine Lösung der ehemaligen
tazautoren Ulrike Herrmann aufgefallen
natürlich habe ich mir gesagt taz das
ist ja nicht gerade mein Leib und
magenblatt und Rezensenten auf Amazon
haben das Buch auch dafür kritisiert
lange Art nicht zu sein muss ich mir das
also wirklich antun andererseits hat
mich anhand der Inhaltsangabe schon
interessiert was da überhaupt drin steht
ja dank der festen geschriebenen Blick
ist Fassung konnte ich innerhalb von nur
25 Minuten herausfinden dass dieses Werk
zumindest in der blink ist Fassung
meinen Horizont durchaus bereichern
konnte solides Wissen dass ich ohne
blinkende sicher verpasst hätte kurz
gesagt diese App wird mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit auch dein Leben
bereichern egal für welches Thema du
dich gerade interessierst die Auswahl
und das Spektrum sind wirklich riesig
von Finanzen über Wissenschaft Politik
Karriere bis zu den klassischen Ratgeber
Themen zur Selbstoptimierung aber man
kann mit blinkist nicht nur sich selbst
sondern auch seine Lieben bereichern es
hat nämlich vor kurzem eine neue
Funktion namens blinkist Connect
eingeführt damit kannst du mein blinkist
Premium-Abo auf zwei verschiedenen
Konten nutzen und zwar ohne zusätzliche
Kosten und das ist noch nicht alles
visualpolitik Zuschauer bekommen nämlich
über den Link in der Videobeschreibung
nicht nur zwei Mitgliedschaften so ein
Preis von einer sondern obendrein noch
25% Rabatt also zögere nicht besorgte
jetzt gleich die kostenlose 7 Tage
Testversion über den Link in der
Beschreibung und fangen dann gleich
damit an deinen Wissenschaft zu
bereichern wie gesagt ausprobieren
kostet nichts und es lohnt sich auf
jeden Fall und wenn du das erledigt hast
können wir dann sofort zur Beantwortung
unserer spannenden Fragen schreiben wird
sich China letzten Endes doch deutlich
auf die Seite Russland schlagen ist
Peking wirklich so neutral wie es
vorgibt was sind die wahren Absichten
China mit ihrem forever friend Putin wer
sitzt bei dieser ganzen Geschichte am
längeren Hebel und wer wird zuletzt noch
lachen aufgepasst
[Musik]
die multipolare Ordnung
schaut euch diese diplomatische Szene
mal von einem anderen Schauplatz aus an
hier seht ihr wann je den Chef der
Zentralkommission für auswärtige
Angelegenheiten der kommunistischen
parteiens also shisha-pings obersten
außenpolitischen Berater und zwar
zusammen mit Vertretern Saudi-Arabiens
und des Irans das sind zwei Länder die
sich schon lange sowohl in Theorie als
auch Praxis hassen mehrfach standen sie
am Rande eines Krieges doch unlängst
haben sie beschlossen wieder
diplomatische Beziehung zueinander
aufzunehmen und das haben Sie dank
Chinas Vermittlung geschafft es war
bislang nicht üblich die Chinesen als
Vermittler bei internationalen Problemen
zu erleben aber es scheint dass das
chinesische Regime jetzt genau diesen
neuen Weg einschlagen will oder Konflikt
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine
scheint da das nächste Betätigungsfeld
zu sein
Ende Februar 2023 etwa zum ersten
Jahrestag des Krieges legte China einen
12 Punkteplan vor der eine politische
Lösung des Konflikts skizzierte
zumindest in der Theorie die Chinesen
hatten nicht einmal vorab die Meinung
der Ukraine zu den 12 vorgestellten
Punkten eingeholt allerdings waren diese
auch nicht sehr prägend tatsächlich
beinhalteten die meisten Punkte
Allgemeinplätze wie die Achtung der
Souveränität aller Länder die
Einstellung der Feindseligkeiten und die
Reduzierung strategischer Risiken aber
das Wichtigste daran war wohl das China
mit diesen Dokument überhaupt so etwas
wie eine Friedensplan losiert hatte
Peking hatte ein Signal gesetzt das ist
an einer friedlichen beiliegendes
Konflikts interessiert sei und bereit
daran zu arbeiten diese Message war dann
wohl auch Grundlage für Headlines wie
diese in den chinesischen Medien die
Reisende der europäischen Staats- und
Regierungschefs nach China
unterstreichen die Rolle Pekings als
friedensförderer und die Europäer selbst
nun sie nahmen Pekings Initiative mit
Wohlwollen bis Unglauben zu Kenntnis sie
dachten sich wohl dass das Ganze
zumindest nicht schaden kann
ich diese Woche zu einer offiziellen
Reise in die Hauptstadt Peking reisen
und in diesem Sinne möchte ich den
chinesischen Präsidentin für seine
Einladung danken denn ich glaube das ist
Europa wichtig ist die Zusammenarbeit
zwischen Europa und China angesichts
globaler grenzüberschreitende
Herausforderungen zu stärken Peter
rossanchez Präsident Spanien
Zweifel bleibt mit dieser ganzen
Geschichte natürlich bestehen denn das
große Fragezeichen ist können wir China
wirklich als neutralen Akteur Betrachten
der in diesen Konflikt zwischen Russland
und der Ukraine als Vermittler auftreten
kann
nun was soll ich sagen Plaudereien wie
die folgende helfen hier wohl nicht
besonders viel weiter im Moment gibt es
Veränderungen wie wir sie seit 100
Jahren nicht mehr erlebt haben und wir
sind diejenigen die diese Veränderungen
gemeinsam vorantreiben ich stimme zu
bitte pass auf Dich auf lieber Freund
also ich weiß nicht wie ihr das seht
aber wenn Ski Putin erzählt dass sie
gemeinsam Veränderungen vorantreiben sie
das nicht nach der besten Ausgangslage
für eine neutrale Vermittlerrolle aus
aber sich jetzt einfach nur auf ein paar
Videosequenzen zu stützen wäre eine
furchtbar vereinfachende und
unglückliche Analyse der ganzen
Situation denn wie nach dem Gipfel durch
sekrette hat China mit den Russen zwar
jede Menge Dokumente unterzeichnet aber
in der heiklen Frage der rüstungshilfe
die kalte Schulter gezeigt das wurde
zwei Wochen später überdeutlich als
Chinas EU-Botschafter wo kommen der New
York Times ein Interview gab wo kommt
sagte picking erkenne bitte die Creme
noch die im September annektierten
Regionen jetzt Johann
als russisch an und unterstütze Moskau
nicht militärisch China habe die
russische Invasion jedoch nicht
verurteilt weil die waren Gründe für
diese Entscheidung komplizierter sein
als im Westen behauptet wird außerdem
sagte der Botschafter dass die
grenzenlose Freundschaft zwischen
Russland und China nichts als Rhetorik
sei zwei weitere Wochen später
telefonierte schiedern mit seinen Ski in
Kiew einen geschlagene Stunde lang
Russland war diesen Krieg vielleicht
nicht gewinnen china möchte nach dem
Konflikt zumindest ein Mitspracherecht
in der Ukraine haben um zu verhindern
dass sich die Ukraine während des
Aufbauprozesses nach dem Konflikt
vollständig den besten zuwendet das
bedeutet zwar nicht das ist irgendwie
konkretes Leben in den chinesischen
zwölf Punkteplan käme aber die Chinesen
demonstrieren damit deutlich dass sie
nicht prinzipiell und bedingungslos
hinter Putin stehen sondern mit der
Ukraine ihr eigenes Ding drehen das
Gespräch zeigte zudem wie schwach Putin
geopolitisch wirklich aufgestellt ist
der russische Exil ist Alexander bloß
Chef lieferte z.B die folgenden Analyse
das Gespräch selenskys mit Ski ist eine
große außenpolitischer Erfolg für den
ukrainischen Präsidenten die Ukraine
zieht Putin buchstäblich die Nase lang
denn diese Hälse Lenski ja für eine
Marionette und gibt zu verstehen wenn es
jemanden gebe mit dem er reden könnte
dann wären es die USA selensky hält
Putin den Spiegel vor und macht diesen
zur Marionette von Ski aber im Gegensatz
zu Putin erreicht er Verhandlungen mit
dem Boss während Putin immer noch auf
den Anruf aus Amerika wartet wir können
also festhalten dass Peking in der Tat
internationale Gespräche über seinen
Friedensplan führt und trotzdem lässt
ist irgendwie den rechten Eifer
vermissen aus diesem Eindruck entsteht
eine provokante Frage könnte es China
schlichtweg egal sein ob der Krieg bald
endet oder nicht
China bemüht sich mit selensky Gespräch
um Schadensbegrenzung in der Ukraine die
präsidentengespräche sollen
sicherstellen dass Peking bei der
nachkriegsregelung einer Rolle spielt
china hat erkannt dass es mehr tun muss
in Europa von seiner Aufrichtigkeit zu
überzeugen wenn es sich an einer
nachkriegsregelung beteiligen will dies
ist besonders wichtig da die EU mit der
Arbeit an einer neuen Politik gegenüber
China beginnt die bis Ende Juni
abgeschlossen sein soll analysten
zufolge hoffentlich China durch eine
neutralere Haltung einen Keil zwischen
die USA und die EU treiben zu können und
gleichzeitig den Entwicklungsländern zu
zeigen dass es im Gegensatz zu
Washington das ist beschuldigt hat
Waffen in den Krieg zu punkten eine
Kraft für den Frieden sei wenn du mehr
Einfluss auf alle haben willst solltest
du den Anschein einer gewissen
Neutralität erwecken sagte Shirin Hong
Professor für internationale Beziehungen
an der Rennen in Universität in Peking
und fügte hinzu dass man mit einem
einfachen Telefonanruf nichts verliere
[Musik]
ja ihr habt richtig gehört das hier ist
die eigentliche Frage lass mich das
ganze erklären ursprünglich war dieser
Krieg für China ein unnötiges ärgernes
und zwar aus folgenden Gründen erstens
plötzlich begann sich alle um ihre
nationale Sicherheit zu sorgens die
westliche Unterstützung für die Ukraine
jemand Hindernisse die als präsidenzfall
für andere Situationen wie zum Beispiel
Taiwan angesehen werden können drittens
die Vereinigten Staaten verbesserten ihr
internationales Ansehen und konnten sich
die Luxus leisten sogar den Verkauf von
spissen Technologie an China
einzuschränken und viertens trug die
kriegsbedingte weltweite
Konjunkturabschwächung dazu bei dass
Chinas Wirtschaftswachstum im Jahr 2022
auf was die Hälfte des Ziels der
Regierung fiel aber wo ein Wille ist ist
auch ein Weg und deshalb passt jetzt auf
denn nun werden wir drei Hauptgründe
nennen warum das chinesische Regime die
Dinge vielleicht gar nicht so sieht wie
wir denken der erste davon hat mit Kohle
zu tun ja unter anderem mit sibirischer
Kohle die nicht mehr nach Europa
verkauft werden kann aber ansonsten
meinte er Kohle im Sinne von Zaster
marmormon Kröten und Piepen es ist der
außerordentliche wirtschaftliche Nutzen
den China aus den westlichen Sanktionen
gegen Russland sieht braucht er einen
konkretes Beispiel dafür werd doch mal
einen Blick auf diese Grafik
Energieträger sind der wichtigste Faktor
bei Chinas important aus Russland
[Musik]
der Krieg die Sanktion und der Rückzug
der Europäer aus Russland haben es China
ermöglicht dort direkt Kurt Mengen an
Gas und Öl zu rahmenpreisen einzukaufen
und das just in einer Zeit in der seiner
Wirtschaft alles andere als gut geht der
in Russland muss so viel wie möglich
verkaufen auch wenn das bedeutet das ist
eine Bodenschätze im Vergleich zu früher
gerade zu verschleudern muss so hat
Russland in den Monaten Januar und
Februar 2023 mit einem Anstieg von fast
24% im Vergleich zum Vorjahr Saudi
Arabien als Chinas größten Öllieferanten
abgelöst
[Musik]
natürlich kann Russland China nicht
beliebig mit Öl im Glas überschwemmen
weil es erstens dafür nicht die nötige
Transportinfrastruktur gibt und zweitens
die Chinesen im Gegensatz zu den
Deutschen schon immer sehr auf ihre
Energie Sicherheit bedacht waren Anfang
2023 lag der Anteil Russland eine
chinesischen energieeinkäufen etwas über
20%, die Möglichkeiten scheinen also
aktuell begrenzt zu sein es gibt nun
jedoch die Idee langfristig die
Lieferung per shift durch den Pipeline
Transport von Gas zu ersetzen da gibt es
zum Beispiel den Versuch den Bau von
power of sciperia 2 zu beschleunigen
einer neuen Gaspipeline die bis zu 50
Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas über eine
Distanz von 2600 km transportieren
könnte das würde derzeitige russische
gas-exportkapazität durch China
verdoppelt
[Musik]
doch es gibt ein Problem bei der ganzen
Geschichte die Chinesen werden bis 2025
schätzungsweise nur 38 Milliarden
Kubikmeter Gas importieren während die
Russen in bis 2030 schon 98 Milliarden
Kubikmeter verkaufen wollen und beim Öl
ist es ähnlich sagen wir es so es gibt
eine große Kluft zwischen dem was China
bereit ist zu kaufen und dem was
Russland wäre verkaufen möchte kurz um
damit die Chinesen zustimmen ihre
energetische Abhängigkeit von Russland
weiter auszubauen muss sich der Gremmel
auf deutlich niedrigere Preise
verpflichten außerdem muss Putin echte
Garantien gewähren und alles tun was
königski sagt denn eines dürfen wir
nicht vergessen dies ist keine
Partnerschaft und dergleichen die guten
alten Zeiten als Mann beim Begriff super
macht neben den USA sofort an Russland
bzw wird Union gedacht hat aber eben
erstmal nicht an China ja diese sind für
alle Zeiten vorbei die grenzenlose
Freundschaft zwischen dem vom Besten
isolierten Russland und China könnte
dazu führen dass Russland zu einer Art
was falsch statt
wenn sich Russland im Ukraine kriegt
militärisch moralisch und ökonomisch
aufreibt oder ach ist aktuell ziemlich
aussieht und hier haben wir den zweiten
großen Vorteil den der Krieg für China
haben könnte viel größeren politischen
Einfluss ein neuer Grad anmacht und
globaler Bedeutung den sie selbst mit
den Begriff der multipolaren Weltordnung
bezeichnet
die Idee der multipolaren Weltordnung
ist es die Machtsphären
russlands-achse zu schaffen die in allen
Bereichen als Gegengewicht sondern USA
bzw der nordatlantischen Achse aus USA
und Europa dienen soll bislang sah die
sino russische oder auch eurasische
Projektidee vor das Moskau und Peking
dabei mehr oder weniger gleichrangig
sind die Russen hätten darin mit ihren
riesigen Rohstoff Ressourcen gepunktet
den Energieträgern und Ärzten und dem
Holz und Wasser Sibiriens außerdem ihren
enormen Agrarflächen und dem großen
Atomwaffenarsenal und vielleicht noch
mit exklusiven GMX wieder einzigen Atom
Eisbrecher Flotte der Welt und die
Chinesen hätten eine hochgradig
innovative und produktive Wirtschaft
Kapital und moderne Technologien
beizusteuern natürlich last but not
least eine Bienen fleißige und
konsumfreudige Bevölkerung die zehn Mal
größer ist als die russische doch die
Koks an der aktuellen Situation ist das
China nun eine enorme selbst verursachte
Schwächung Russland ausnutzen könnte um
seine geopolitischen wirtschaftlichen
und militärischen Interessen ohne
große Rücksicht auf die russischen
wünschen und Ansprüche durchzusetzen
wohin dies führen könnte nun eines der
möglichen Szenarien in denen China
Russland als Wasser nutzen könnte um
sein Einfluss auszubauen wäre das
Engagement in Afrika zum Beispiel indem
es versucht die militärische Kapazität
moskauz etwa im Form von mobilen Wagnis
soll dann mit seinen eigenen konkreten
wirtschaftlichen Interessen in dem einen
oder anderen afrikanischen Land zu
verknüpfen aber es geht nicht nur um den
geostrategischen Bereich wenn wir über
Chinas macht sprechen es geht auch um
die nackte Ökonomie sieht euch mal
folgendes an Putin sagte Ski Russland
sei bereit im Außenhandel aufzustellen
im Grunde würde diese Änderung bedeuten
dass Russland seine handeln mit Ländern
in Asien hat ein Amerika und Afrika
nicht mehr in Dollar sondern in ein Mini
der allgemein als Yuan bekannten
chinesischen Währung abwickeln würde
tatsächlich stieg der andere an den
russischen exportzahlungen im Jahr 2022
von 0,5% auch 16 % und im Februar 2023
überholte der Julian zum ersten Mal in
der Geschichte den Dollar als meist
gehandelte Währung an der Moskauer Börse
auf die chinesische Währung in vielen
fast 40 Prozent der Transaktionen manche
sprechen da schon vom petrolue an doch
ehrlich gesagt wird die Bedeutung dieser
Verschiebungen stark übertrieben der
johannist Global nicht in der Lage den
Dollar zu ersetzen warum vor allem weil
es ihm an Rechtssicherheit mangelt und
weil China strenge
Kapitalverkehrskontrollen aufrecht
erhält aber auch so könnte diese
Veränderung Chinas Einfluss auf Russland
und generell in der gesamten
zentralasiatischen Regierung stärken und
schließlich ist da noch die militärische
Frage
Russland erlebt und erleidet in der
Ukraine eine enorme militärische
Zermürbung die zusammen mit den
Sanktionen zwei ganz klare Folgen hat
einerseits ist Russlands militärische
Kapazität enorm geschwächt so dass China
praktisch die einzige große Militär
macht ein Zentralasien bleibt
andererseits wird sich Russland wenn der
Krieg erstmal vorbei ist und es neue
militärische Ausrüstung anschaffen muss
um seine Verluste zu ersetzen
wahrscheinlich an die chinesischen
Rüstungsindustrie wenden ja sogar wenden
müssen wenn die Sanktion des Westens
nicht so schnell aufgehoben werden und
das gilt nicht nur für Russland nachdem
was viele Kunden der russischen
Rüstungsindustrie in der Ukraine gesehen
haben könnten sie nach und nach auf
chinesische Lieferanten umsteigen
das wären also schon mal drei Aspekte
bei denen ich China von diesen debatel
profitieren könnte drei Kernideen mit
den schießen bringen den heftigen
Rückschlag denen in der Krieg zugefügt
hat wieder ausbügeln will aber genau an
dieser Stelle kommen sowohl er als auch
Putin in eine großes Dilemma hört gut zu
denn jetzt wird es wirklich interessant
[Musik]
das große dilem
wenn ihr nach allem was wir in diesem
Video aufgezählt haben die
anfangsgestellte Frage beantworten
müsstet ob China wirklich neutral
gegenüber Russland ist oder nicht welche
Antwort würdet ihr geben klar ist China
nimmt keine neutrale Position einfach
allem weil in diesen Krieg einen
weiteren Weg gefunden hat um seine
eigene Agenda der Konfrontation mit dem
besten durchzusetzen der beste Proxy in
einem Krieg ist eben jemand der glaubt
er würde vor allem in seinem eigenen
Interesse handeln nicht in dem seines
dritten Ziels die Kette der nützlichen
Idioten kann manchmal länger sein als
ihnen denken außerdem dürfen wir nicht
vergessen dass die chinesische
Wirtschaft langsam in Schwierigkeiten
gerät in so einer Lage gibt es nichts
besseres als einen Sündenbock zur Hand
zu haben ihr wisst ja wie das läuft nein
wir sind nicht selber schuld an den
Problemen es liegt am Krieg doch das ist
nicht die ganze Geschichte genau hier
sind wir beim großen Dilemma angelangt
vor den die chinesische Regierung steht
einerseits kann der russische
ukrainische Krieg wie wir gesehen haben
Vorteile für die Agenda bringen
andererseits bringt aber auch viele
Probleme die von den Medien meist
übersehen werden
zum Beispiel veranlasst der Krieg Chinas
Nachbarn ihre Militärausgaben zu erhöhen
und näher an die Vereinigten Staaten
heran zu rücken dies kann Chinas
Ambitionen die dominierende Macht im
asiatisch-pazifischen Raum zu werden
strukturell Schwächen gleichzeitig trägt
der Konflikt zur weiteren
Verschlechterung der ohnehin schon
angespannten wirtschaftlichen und
politischen Beziehungen Chinas zum
Westen bei und das ist etwas was China
im Moment zumindest so überhaupt nicht
gebrauchen kann sagen so dieser Krieg
hat viele Regierungen dazu gebracht
Diktatoren wie die von Putin und als
nicht vertrauenswürdig zu betrachten
[Musik]
erschwerend kommt hinzu dass der Krieg
auch das globale Wirtschaftswachstum
bremst ein Wachstum das China jetzt mehr
denn je braucht und zwar um all die
Probleme zu überwinden mit denen es in
der postcode Epoche konfrontiert ist wir
reden hier von Dingen wie den Plasten
Immobilienblase der technologiekrise den
Problemen in Bankensektor der
Überschuldung der lokalen Regierungen
und so weiter und so fort wir haben über
all das hier auf visualpolitik schon
eine ganze Reihe von Videos gedreht wenn
es den chinesischen Führungskader nicht
gelingt all diese Ungleichgewichte zu
überwinden könnte die neue multipolare
Weltordnung von der sie so sehr Träumen
nur von kurzer Dauer sein es scheint ja
das ist das Ruder im Vergleich zu seinem
konzilianten Vorgängern sie nicht
dramatische herum gerissen hat aber
seine Ergebnisse sind bislang alles
andere als eindrucksvoll wir werden über
schieß kolossale Felsen noch ein eigenes
Video herausbringen deshalb scheint die
gegen durchaus interessiert zu sein an
einem neuen Spiel nämlich den vom Krieg
den Russland in der Ukraine vom Zaun
gebrochen hat maximal zu profitieren
natürlich ist uns hier und heute noch
nicht klar ob China wirklich nutzen aus
diesem Spiel ziehen kann klar ist nur in
Sachen Ukraine ist China wieder ein
neutrales Land noch eine verlässliche
Stütze definitiv nicht für die Ukraine
und den Westen aber eben auch nicht für
Putin Russland
es ist ziemlich logisch dass die
Chinesen keine Lust haben sich eng mit
einem potenziellen Verlierer zu
verbinden Allianzen sollen ein Jahr
schließlich stärken und nicht
herunterziehen und noch sind Sie sich
nicht sicher wie Putins gewagtes Ukraine
Abenteuer aus geht solange Russland eine
Chance hat es einigermaßen stabil zu
überstehen halten sie Putin die Stange
warum einerseits um den USA zu
demonstrieren dass sie eben nicht die
einzig entscheidende Weltmacht auf dem
Globus sind und andererseits weil ihnen
Russlands neue Abhängigkeit von Chinas
Märkten und Lieferanten ganze wunderbar
in den Kram passt und Putin
Herrschaftsstil sowieso denn der hat im
eigenen Land ja sowieso all diese
störenden westlichen wie Demokratie
Menschenrechte und Meinungsfreiheit in
den einmal getreten deshalb steht Peking
zu Putin und falls der mal nicht mehr
sein sollte wird es auch dessen
Nachfolgern die Hand reichen wenn Sie
den schön auf diese Linie bleiben
Stabilität und klare Verhältnisse weiß
man den Peking schließlich sehr zu
schätzen doch was passiert wenn in
Russland das ganze System Putin
kollabieren infolge einer unheilvollen
Konstellation politischer Faktoren ich
meine da gibt es hier einige ganz reale
neben Putins angeschlagener Gesundheit
die vermutlich vehemente gegen Offensive
der ukrainischen Armee die
kriegsmöglichkeit in Armee sowie unter
den Eliten drohende Machtkämpfe die
gestresste wirtschaftliche und
finanzielle Lage und so weiter sollte
also die Russische Föderation in eine
drastische Existenzkrise geraten wie 91
schon die home-reiche soweit Union was
viele Experten absehbarer Zeit durchaus
für möglich halten was würde der große
Bruder China dann Unternehmen wird er
sich der Cent heraushalten oder
umgekehrt sich massiv einmischen im
Bestreben irgendwie wieder oben beim
nördlichen Nachbarn für hohen Ordnung zu
sorgen oder wird Peking einem Chaos
versinkendes Russland einfach nur
betrachten die einen gigantischen
Räumungsverkauf in einem pleite
gegangenen Rohstoff Supermarkt und sich
schamlos bedienen nach dem Motto
osziieren heute im ultra günstigen
Sonderangebot drei Ölfelder zum Preis
von einem und wäre ja gut sie in dem
Paket mit Sachalin kauft bekommt den
Baikalsee gratis dazu entsprechende
Pläne haben sicherlich nicht nur Chinas
Wirtschaftskapitäne in der Schublade
sondern auch politische Strategen
[Musik]
ja es geht um konkrete territoriale
Ansprüche denn die Geschichte der beiden
riesenreiche bietet genügend Spielraum
für chinesischen Revisionismus und
Revanchismus zum Beispiel in der
russischen Republik Tuba sie hat eine
Fläche so groß wie die drei baltischen
Staaten zusammen und liegt an der Grenze
zur Mongolei die meiste Zeit seiner
Geschichte wurde dieses Gebiet von China
kontrolliert doch ab 1912 Gerät ist
unter russischen Einfluss anfangs des
Zarenreichs dann das verwirrunion die
Phase der formellen Unabhängigkeit des
bitte Armen sowie Satelliten Stars
endete 1944 sang und klanglos mit einem
Beitrag mit Union im Status einer
russischen Teil Republik du warst
vereinnahmen durch die Russen von den
Chinesen hat also grob 30 Jahre gedauert
weit im Osten finden wir das Amur Gebiet
und das Küstengebiet mit Wladiwostok
eine riesiges Territorium das Russland
um 1860 den damals sehr schwachen China
einfach abpresste schließlich gehört wie
auch die ganze äußerer Mann schonerei
als durch chinesischen Kinder und hieß
früher heilen das logische Reich
annektierte die Region im Jahr 1860
während der Schwächephase Chinas nach
der Niederlage gegen die Briten und
Franzosen im zweiten Opiumkrieg diese
Schmach sitzt in Chinesen noch immer
ziemlich tief in den Knochen die
Versuchung ist sehr groß den Spieß
umzudrehen und sich das zurückzuholen
was der Zar dem Kaiser einst gestohlen
hat aber wie realistisch ist diese
Agenda nun in nationalistischen Kreisen
Chinas wird schon lange ganz offen
gefordert dass diese Demütigung durch
Russland wieder gut gemacht werden muss
und es wird auch ganz offen darüber
debattiert wie China den Osten der
Russischen Föderation wieder
vereinnahmen könnte die herrschende
sogenannte Kommunistische Partei Chinas
hatte dem Nationalismus jedoch
eigentlich abgeschworen da seine
Vertreter einen guten gegnerabgaben der
Punkt ist jedoch dies hat sich
unterschiedliche Ping diamental geändert
schließlich hat er die nationalistische
Klaviatur schon vor Jahren als äußerst
nützliches Propaganda Instrument
entdeckt trotzdem offiziell immer wieder
verkündeten unendlichen Freundschaften
mit Putin Russland erinnern chinesische
Medien daher immer
öfter an die durch Russland überhaupt
nicht chinesischen Territorien und auch
an die Tatsache dass der Kreml selbst
immer wieder Anspruch auf jedes Gebiet
erhebt das in den letzten tausend Jahren
mal irgendwie unter russischer
verwaltungsstand oder eine russisch
sprachige Bevölkerung hat das Problem
mit alten Gebietsansprüchen gegen andere
ist dass man diesen Spieß genauso gut
umdrehen kann aber während Russland im
Falle Finnland oder Georgiens durch das
Machtgefälle zu diesem kleinen Ländern
seine Ruhe hatte ist dies im Falle
Chinas ganz anders pickingsansprüche auf
russlandsflammen Osten sind nicht nur
Fakten basiert und unbestreitbar sondern
können auch real umgesetzt werden
chinesische Karten aus dem 13
jahrhundert zeigen das Gebiet unplug als
Junge chinesischen Ohren klingt daher
einfach nur wie eine kolonialistische
Anmaßung unter China Strategen wird das
Thema der anhaltenden kolonialen
Besetzung der chinesischen Gebiete durch
Russland und die langfristige
Notwendigkeit einer Entkolonialisierung
immer häufiger angesprochen und
natürlich ist man sich in Peking auch
über Putin selektiven Imperialismus
bewusst und das Verträge Garantie
Bündnisse immer den
Geschichtsverständnis des Kremls oder
der russischen Militärmacht
untergeordnet sind deshalb wissen Sie
dass es umso wichtiger ist auch
innerhalb der chinesischen Bevölkerung
des narrativ des eigenen
geschichtsverhältnisses und der eigenen
territorialen Ansprüche wach zu halten
um es dann sobald die Zeit erreicht ist
im Rahmen einer vollkommen natürlichen
Entwicklung aktivieren zu können das ist
in der Tat eine Leichtigkeit denn wie
gesagt die chinesischen Ansprüche auf
den russischen Fernen Osten sind
bedeutend und sie basieren auf klaren
historischen Fakten
bis zur sowjetischen massenreportation
gab es in dieser ganzen Region eine
bedeutende chinesische Bevölkerung die
von Russland betriebene ethnische
Säuberung des fernen Ostens von den
Chinesen erreichte in den 1930er Jahren
ihren Höhepunkt vor der russischen
Revolution machten die Chinesen 41
Prozent der registrierten Arbeitskräfte
in den damaligen oblasten Armor und
primors aus die tatsächliche Zahl war
wahrscheinlich noch viel höher da viele
Chinesen saisonal grenzüberschreitend
als Tagelöhner arbeiteten ethnische
Russen waren damals in der Minderheit
wogegen ist Darling das altbewährte
russische Allheilmittel der
unmenschlichen Politik der
Massenvertreibung zum Einsatz brachte
und die russische Vorherrschaft zu
zementieren all das hat man in Peking
nicht nur nicht vergessen man hält die
Erinnerung danach auch aktiv und
zielgerichtet war klar momentan braucht
man Russland noch als nützlichen Idioten
als Störfaktor der aktuellen Weltordnung
und billigen Rohstofflieferanten aber
dies alles wird sich in Zukunft ändern
denn die wirklichen strategischen
Vorteile für China liegen nicht in der
Stärke Russland sondern in eine
anhaltenden Verschlechterung der
russischen Wirtschaft und Demographie
und dieser Plan läuft schließlich wie
geschmiert Putins Reich fällt Kriegs
sanktions- und migrationsbedingt
technologisch und wirtschaftlich immer
weiter zurück von data-mürbung der
Militärmacht ganz zu schweigen und bis
25 wird es wohl mindestens weitere 12
Millionen seine 145 Millionen Einwohner
verlieren das lange Sichtum Russlands
eröffnet China eine viel größere Auswahl
an Optionen mit seinem schrumpfenden
Nachbarn nach gute zu verfahren als wenn
es vor Vitalität trotzdem würde wenn die
aktuellen Trends anhalten kann China
davon ausgehen dass ihm seine alten
Gebiete eines Tages sogar automatisch in
den Schoß fallen lernen ich meine die
Kommunistische Partei hat schließlich
schon oft bewiesen dass sie nicht nur
ein sehr langes Gedächtnis hat sondern
auch ein außerordentliches
behaarungsvermögen um historische
Territorien zurück zu gewinnen Japan
Großbritannien und Tai waren können ein
Lied davon singen und daher ist es eher
unwahrscheinlich dass Peking bei
Russland eine Ausnahme machen wird warum
auch es wäre langfristig zum eigenen
Nachteil daher kann China darauf hoffen
den fernen Osten Russlands zu
entkolonialisieren indem es einfach den
derzeitigen langfristigen strategischen
Weg fortsetzt Peking schaltet dieser
Hinsicht wirklich alles richtig zu
machen es verschafft sich einen billigen
und sicheren Zugang zu russischen
Ressourcen macht dabei aber nicht sich
von Russland abhängig sein den
geldhungrigen und isolierten Kreml vom
eigenen Wohlwollen das gleiche gilt für
die sinusierung der Lieferketten der
russischen Wirtschaft die Zeit spielt
nun mal für den wirtschaftlich viel
größeren Nachbarn der deswegen gerne
vorgibt ein unendlicher Freund zu sein
China entsende sondergesanden in die
Ukraine und nach Russland als Teil der
Friedensbemühungen der Besuch des
chinesischen Vertreters in den
betreffenden Ländern bringt Chinas
Engagement für die Förderung von Frieden
und Verhandlungen zum Ausdruck sagte der
sprechendes chinesischen
Außenministeriums
möchte ich China eine Eskalation der
Situation verhindern
[Musik]
es ist kein Zufall dass ich Peking
gerade jetzt plötzlich so stark ins Zeug
legt um für Friedensverhandlungen zu
werben ausgerechnet jetzt nachdem die
russische Offensive ihren Höhepunkt
überschritten hat die Ukraine wieder die
militärische Initiative übernimmt und
mit einer massiven Gegenoffensive Putins
Militärmaschinerie zu zerschlagen droht
ein schneller Sieg der Ukraine und
anschließender Zusammenbruch Russland
wäre für Peking der wurstcase ein
Waffenstillstand hingegen viel besser
Russland würde militärisch und politisch
nicht kollabieren aber weiterhin durch
Sanktionen und Isolation wirtschaftlich
erdrückt werden gleichzeitig könnte er
sich militärisch wieder berappeln um die
Ukraine auf vielfältige Weise weiterhin
zu terrorisieren und den Konflikt zu
über viele Jahre hinauszuziehen es würde
so für dauerhaft Instabilität in Europa
sorgen während es von China immer
abhängiger wird und genau deswegen kann
sich China Zeit lassen die chinesische
Bevölkerung ist zehnmal so groß wie die
russische und dennoch entfällt auf jeden
Russen 17,5 mal mehr Land als auf eine
Chinesen aufgrund seiner extremen aus
Verbindung haben die Russen es nie
geschafft ihr landkonsistent urbar zu
machen und mit den Erträgen daraus ein
funktionierendes Straßennetz aufzubauen
da ist auch kaum geeignete Wasserwege
gibt mussten und müssen Sie alles über
die Eisenbahn transportieren die jedoch
sowohl kapazitativ stark begrenzt als
auch sehr unflexibel ist auch Putin hat
sich ja kaum darum geschert die immensen
rohstoffprofite in Infrastruktur die
Landwirtschaft und allgemein die urbar
machen seines Riesenreichs zu
investieren nein anstatt dass viele Land
das den Russen zur Verfügung steht
ordentlich zu bewirtschaften will man
noch mehr Land erobern oder urbares Land
in der Ukraine zerbomben und verseuchen
in den Augen der fleißigen und
aufbauorientierten Chinesen ist dies
natürlich ein übler Friedel die Russen
konnten kulturell gar nicht weiter von
ihnen entfernt sein den Chinesen
erscheint ist deswegen geradezu als
natürliche Pflicht die vernachlässigten
als blühenden wie chinesischen
Landschaften wieder auf Vordermann zu
bringen chinesische Landwirte arbeiten
bereits auf russischen Boden entfernen
Osten und chinesische Unternehmen sind
dort sehr stark vertreten gerade die
Wirtschaft dort wird immer abhängiger
von den wesentlich besser gebildeten und
produktiveren Chinesen daher ist es für
sie jetzt zunächst klüger die
wirtschaftliche Präsenz auszubauen
welche meist auch mit dem Zuzug
ethnischer Chinesen verboten ist aber
für die Zeit danach wenn ausreichend
Fakten geschaffen sind ist das
rhetorische und ideologische Rüstzeug
schon mal vorhanden durch die starke
Präsenz in Russland hatte chinesischen
Führung vielleicht auch ein besseres
Verständnis für den Niedergang seines
Nachbarns als seine westlichen Kollegen
und weiß wohl auch die andauernden
nukleare Tour des Kreml besser
einzuordnen denn mit jeder atomaren
Drohung wird deutlicher das putinsreich
ein wirtschaftlicher und militärischer
Zwerg im Vergleich zu seiner
geografischen Größe ist in Peking fällt
man daher nicht so leicht auf die
russische Propaganda und das
Säbelrasseln herein es wäre daher
unlogisch dass China Russland als
ebenbürtiges Supermacht behandelt und
selbst vor einer militärischen Besetzung
russischer Gebiete zurückschreckt vor
allem wenn man dies dann sogar als
humanitäre Hilfe für einen im Chaos
zerfallendes und von Warlords
zerrissenes Russland verkaufen könnte
schon Sonja
nationalistische Vater des modernen
Chinas drängte auf die
Entkolonialisierung des russischen
Fernen Ostens und die Umsiedlung von
Hand und mandschuh Chinesen in ihr
angestammtes Land doch dann stoppte die
chinesische Revolution jede weitere
Diskussion zu diesem Thema nun werden
seine Botschaften jedoch von der KPC
höchstpersönlich wieder hervorgeholt
selbst die pseudo-kommunisten geraten in
starke Wehmut wenn Sie sich an den
früheren Status und die damalige
Demütigung durch Russland erinnern aber
noch braucht man Russland wie gesagt für
andere Zwecke noch ist der richtige
Moment nicht gekommen aber die
Geschichte hat uns gelehrt dass sich
Chinas doppelte und dreifache Spiele
über Dekaden erstrecken können es hat
westliche Unternehmen mit riesigen
versprechen und einem großen Lächeln ins
Land gelockt nur um ihn Know-how
übernehmen zu können und sie dann aus
dem Land zu kicken sobald sie nicht mehr
nützlich sind diese gezielte Verstellung
und Ausnutzung ist eine chinesische
Tradition die auch gesellschaftlich
moralisch akzeptiert ist im Westen fehlt
dafür häufig das Verständnis genauso wie
für die Fähigkeit der Chinesen dieses
doppelte Spiel extrem lange durchhalten
zu können bis eben die eigenen Ziele
erreicht sind anders ausgedrückt auch
wenn der russische Ferne Osten jetzt
militärisch leer gefegt der kremme zum
internationalen Paare ja geworden ist
und seine Wirtschaft unter der Last der
westlichen Sanktion rechts werden wir
keinen plumpen Einfall chinesischer
Truppen aller Unternehmen Barbarossa
erleben aber China wird gegenüber
Russland hart bleiben und seine
Forderungen ständig erhöhen es fährt
eine erbarmungslose Salamitaktik daher
kann überblasi was dort noch eine ganze
Weile die russische Flagge sehen aber
mit der Gewissheit das ist eines Tages
höchstwahrscheinlich wieder highschild
eine Stadt in China werden wird
[Musik]
zugegeben ein solches Szenario erscheint
vielen momentan noch ziemlich
fantastisch zu sein wobei wir
vorausschauend zum potenziellen
möglichen Zerfall Russlands bereits ein
Video gemacht haben ich lasse euch
verlinken also schaut euch an aber jetzt
kommen wir erstmal wieder schnell zurück
auf den harten Boden der heutigen
Realität und zwar mit unseren
traditionellen abschlussfragen an euch
glaubt ihr Peking könne vom Ukraine
kriegt profitieren indem es als
Vermittler auftritt oder umgekehrt indem
es den Konflikt bewusst laufen lässt
welche Zukunft prognostiziert ihr einen
Bündnis zwischen China und Russland
könnten diese beiden großen Player
wirklich in der Lage sein eine neue
Weltordnung zu schaffen oder der
garantiert Russland am Ende nur zu einem
puren was zahlen statt Chinas also so
Pekings Tankstelle wie immer sind wir
schon sehr gespannt was ihr darüber zu
sagen habt und wenn ihr dieses Video
interessant fandet vergesst nicht es zu
liken und visualpolitik zu abonnieren um
auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben teilt es
bitte auch mit euren Freunden und
diskutiert es mit ihm und falls Ihr
unsere Arbeit unterstützen möchtet könnt
ihr uns eine freiwillige Spende über den
Link in der Beschreibung zu kommen
lassen wir dank en euch schon mal im
Voraus alles Gute und bis zum nächsten
Mal
[Musik]